Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to The Final One.
Now, this is supposedly an indie horror game that features terrifying, creepy dolls in some sort of fashion,
which is always an A+ in my book and I'm eager to see what sort of sudo-mannequin-esq thing is going to be in this one.
*story begins to unfold*
Woman: "Okay, from what you told, you think there is someone starting these troubles up."
"Right?"
Mark: Yee-
Man: "Yes, just like I told you. In the competitive world of business, we would use any method, in all means, to crush our rivals."
"No matter how much we get our hands dirty."
Woman: "I agree, but don't you think spreading rumors about haunted ghosts is a bit irrational?"
*long pause*
Mark: Noooo? Oh.
"Yeah, I think it's silly too."
"However, it does cause a delay of the construction of my resort."
"The laborers ran away and it affects a lot of my plan."
Woman: "I understand."
Man: That's the reason why I want you to investigate and seek proof,
-because from my own opinion, I don't think those kind of rumors would really affect my employees."
Woman: "Do not worry. Maybe they are hiring your employee to do that."
Man: "OR, they were murdered."
Mark: *shocked* Wuh-
Woman: "Trust me, I'll do my best in the investigation-"
"-but I think it's a plan of your rivals."
Man: "I think of that, too."
"I'll leave it to you, then."
Mark: Whaa...?
Woman: "I give my word that I won't disappoint you."
Mark: Ohh.
Man: "I believe in you. Haha, just don't get haunted by the ghost, then."
Woman (laughing): "Haha. sure."
Mark: Hahahahaha.
What are the odds that that could happen in-
Woman: "So now, we're going to find out [Mark: Lil' Docka.] what's happening.
"Inside the museum."
Ok. Alright. So, supposedly this business man hired this investigator to see if it's haunted with ghosts-
-but this business, or, uh, the investigator thinks that maybe it was just business rivals trying to do stuff. But, why would he not be able to know where his employees are?
How would he not know if they're murdered or not? Did they just run away without telling anybody? Did no one go here?
*door opens* Why am I here?
*steps* Why am I- okay. Here we go then.
Okay.
Oh, this looks good! Oh, yeah, I've seen great many museums that are haunted in my day.
And this ranks up at the top. Oh. Hi.
Hello. Oh, God, hi.
Hello! Oh, I don't like you already!
Oh, I can already tell how much I hate you. Ohh, I am not going to have fun here.
Alrighty then, let's see what's going on in this horrible museum. Like what kind of business is this?
This is the worst museum ever!
Why would he have anybody working here?
Why am I working here?
Ohh, it's behind me, isn't it?
Okay, find the way to operate the elevator.
I-I-I'm in it to win it. Hang on one second.
I got to crank up the volume, so I can hear myself and everything that's going to kill me.
Alright.
*door opens* Hi! Hello!
Sorry to disturb you, go back to sleep!
Let me look at my objective before I find out what's going to kill me.
Hel- oh, hi. Oh, mini dolls! Oh, you're probably just as lethal.
Ooh. I thought something was behind me.
Okay. There's a lot of you.
Why are there a lot of you?
Oh, hi.
Eh.
Ehhh.
Ehhhh.
Ehhgh.
Alright.
[There's creepy background noise, like children's screams echoed from a distance throughout the game]
You know, if the chorus of babies could stop-
screaming for one second, maybe I could get some concentration going on here.
Oh, what's in here?
Ooo! That looks highly technical and advanced. Why is it here?
Hello.
Oh, I can save! Oh, that's awfully convenient.
Ok, well, that shut behind me, didn't it? Ah, piss.
Oh, hello. Hi. Alrighty, then.
Beep, boop, beepity, boop.
*creepy background noises continue*
The cacophony of screaming toddlers has not subsided.
Hi.
Hello.
Yeah, that's probably a good idea.
Don't know why that required a cut scene, but okay!
Let me save one more do-dadi time..
Let me guess, all the mannequins are gone now,
and I'm not going to- *glass shatters* Hello? Oh, you're still there!
Ohhh, you're delightful, maybe.
Ohh, hey! Ohh, I didn't notice the painting. The really disconcerting painting.
Why would anybody make a painting of dolls?
Ok. You're still there. Let's play- hey! That's what this video is.
Ok. Glad you know the subject matter.
Ohhh, you're lovely.
Oh, you're so lovely.
Ehhh. (x2)
Ehh. *through clenched teeth* I'm so tense!
Alright, is there anything else over here?  Oh, okay, never mind then!
That plant was blocking my way.
Guess I'll go to the elevator now.
Goodbye, everybo-  *glass shatters* -body!  Hey, fuck you!
Hi. Ok. Hello! My name is Markiplier, do you want to be part of this Let's Play, too- oh, God, hi.
Okay, should I- *woman screeching* I should RUN. Woooahhkay!
Ayyy, alrighty, then.
*scary, hurry music*
*banging on elevator door*
*orchestra ends abruptly*
Who's there..?
Anybody? Okay.
Alright. Off we go, then!
I think I'm okay.
Now, I can finish off this investigation in peace.
Oh. Hi! Uh, I think I found the missing employees!
He might not be dead.
That is an option.
Oh, do I get a- *giggle* Do I get a gun?
Oh, hell yeah!
Oh, okay. I don't know why my first instinct was to try to shoot that guy-
-but that probably wasn't a good thing.
So, if he had a gun, why didn't that work for him?
Eugh. That is a cinematic piece of masterpiece right there.
Okie-dokie then!
I'll save. Yeah, sure, okay!
Who wants to come get some?
I've got a heaping, helping load of- *girl shrieking* BULLETS! Ah, geez.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop.
I just had the craziest flashback to Cry of Fear.
Like, I legitimately had the craziest flashback to like, four years ago,
-when I was playing Cry of Fear, because I remember the cacophony of screaming children-
-in a lot of games, but for some reason that REALLY reminded me of Cry of Fear.
And this- wait a minute.
I bet if I reload this gun it's going to lose the bullets that are in it, so I'm going to keep that.
And then hopefully-
*SUDDEN LOUD MUSIC*
Aghh, FUCK YOU. Woah, hi.
Oh, God, what the fuck?
That is SO Cry of Fear.
Ohhhh.
Also, ow!
What- woah.
That is SO Cry of Fear!
Oh, hello. Okay.
Goodbye.
But, hello.
Alrighty, then.
Eugh.
First Aid, yes, please, and thank you.
I don't know how to use the First Aid- *screeching*
AHHHHH! *gunshots*
Jeeeezuuums, NOOO!!!
How about you don't do that, ya crazy, crazy doll!
Eugh.
I bet I didn't need to unload my entire clip from the gun, but-
-it felt like it was necessary in the moment.
Find the power room's key.
Okay, can do.
This staircase doesn't make a lot of sense, but okay, whatever.
*immense noise* EHH, fuck you!
Fuck off, fuck off. Don't throw rocks at me!
God, you boulder-hurling bastard. *more girl screeching*
Fuckin' I don't have enough bullets for this!
AHH! AHH!
No, no, no, no, no, dooon't.
That is 100% so Cry of Fear and I love that.
Man, it's been so long since I played that game.
I always meant to go back and finish it, the, uh- the super extra way.
Don't even think about!
Maybe you're the peaceful one.
Maybe you're not actually goi- *girl screaming* No, woah, hey, woah, hey, woah.
Alright. Nope. Nope. Nope, nope, nope.
Alright, reloading.
Boap, boap, boap, beh, beh, beh, beh, okay, got you.
Alright, I can reload. I can waste one bullet.
Better than being caught with my pants down when screamers are sprinting down my face.
Okay! Alrighty, then.
Ooh, is that a key?
Is that the key I need? Is that an employee?
Is he deead?
*loud thuds* Eh, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope!
Ow. My grundle.
Aw, fucking goddammit, my stupid FPS instincts.
Yeah, in Cry of Fear, you had to, uh- you had to conserve your ammo a lot!
You had to make that you didn't reload because obviously, if you're in a horror situation, you wouldn't-
-have time to exchange the bullets from one clip to another.
Hi. How you doin'?
Okay. This is cool, by the way.
I like this a lot.
Ooooohh.
Ehhhhhhhh, I don't like that!
Can I get out? Can I just dive head-first through the window and get out?
That'd be really nice.
Okay, the elevator's working now. That's awfully convenient for me and everybody around here.
Hope I have enough bullets.
*screeching, random gunshots* Hey!
Who's doing that? Who?
Hiiiii.
Hello?
Who else is here helping me?
Who's a helpy-helperton?
Someone in here, maybe?
No?
It won't open.
Okay, then.
I'll be on my way.
Oh.
Woman: "Mr. Wilhem? [Mark: Oh?] Are you alright?"
"Why are you here?"
Mr. Wilhem: "Ah. Ugh. I have been kidnapped for three days."
Woman: "But I just talked to you on the phone."
Mr. Wilhem: "That wasn't me. Ugh."
'i'm not going to make it."
*heavy breathing*
"But I have gathered all the evidence. It's in the office room, on the first floor."
"Ugh. You should go there and you will know the truth."
Mark: Oh, okay.
Woman: "Mr. Wilhelm! Mr. Wilhelm!
Mark: Uh, oh.
Well, he survived three days.
Woman: "I have to know what's happening here."
Mark: And then he died just in time to-
Woman: "It seems like I will have to go to the office room [Mark: Yeah. Yeah, it kinda seems like that] to get the answer."
Mark: He died just in time to give me a plot device.
Well, sorry Mr. WIlhelm.
Do you have any ammo that I could use? You still seem to be breathing.
I don't think you're dead yet, but, you know, I am not going to help you.
I'm just going to walk away and imagine all the other things I can do in my life while I'm not dead.
Okay, goodbye!
Ding-dong, bing-bong.
Okay? I guess I got to go to the office and discover the TRUTH, whatever the TRUTH may be.
Whatever the TRUTH may hold.
Also, sorry, like- if I'm a little lispy and spitty today, it's because yesterday we did a challenge where- that involved war heads and we melted off the entirety-
-of our mouth. So, it's- it's a- it's a little, a LITTLE uncomfortable to talk, and it just seems like I'm slightly inebriated.
But, uh- trust me, I am not. I can't drink.
I'll die.
*sudden screeching* WOAH, WHAT THE FUCKIN' DELAYED-REACTION, DOOR.
I never expected the delayed-reaction door.
Oh, man! *giggles* Oh, okay. Alright. Sorry.
Physics-based delayed-reaction door.
Alright, Imma go- wait, did I miss something over here?
Oh, I did.
No, wait, I saved, that was it.
Oh, God.
i don't want to go down there.
Okay!
*click* Hello? Alright, which one of these doors is gonna- *doll emerges loudly* -crumble on me?
Nope, nope, ain't gonna hit me. *gunshots*
Missed me. And now you're dead.
*click* Find the key to open the office room.
Okay, so that's the office. I got some extra ammo.
And I'm doing pretty good on able to kill these things.
It's been a while since I've played a horror game that actually involved combat, becau- *girl screeching*
Bah, fuck you. *gunshots* Woah, what the fuck.
*gunshot* Because usually- not always, but usually- combat removes a little bit of the scare to it because you're, you're, you're less- you know, you're less-
-threatened when you're just you and yourself with a GUN, instead of just using yourself with shit in your pants.
You know? It's usually like a trade-off, but, in this one, it seems to be working pretty well because the original Cry of Fear was all about weapons and killing the things,
-but it was just so interesting in the diverse environment that you were in, that it created this, uh, unique world that was just fun to go through and terrifying at the same time.
And always with the new monsters coming around every corner, it really made it diverse.
Woman: "Here it is."
Mark: Okay. The truth!
The truth!
Wilhelm: "Hi, I am Wilhelm Gefharweitz."
"If you are listening to this, perhaps I am no longer alive."
Mark: That wasn't him up there either.
Wilhelm: "I have found the truth about the mystery of this museum."
"In the past, this place was a nursery that looked after the children-"
"-who were affected by World War II."
Mark: Noble.
Wilhelm: "After that, this place was burned."
"And I found out that it was caused by the denomic rituals."
Woman: "What?"
Mark: Yeah, what?
Wilhelm: "In the rituals, the host must kill the victim as a sacrifice to Satan."
Mark, quietly:  the Satan..?
[quick note, the voices speak in not-my-first-language English voices, so Mark was kinda pointing to that with the previous comment]
"They believe that if they offer a lot of people at the same time at the same place in the most torturous of ways, they will gain incredible power."
"It leads the host to be successful in their life and nothing can stop them."
"They will be more powerful than any human being.
"Now, I guess you know what I mean. It is regretful to hear that everyone was killed."
"The fire burned everything into ashes."
"Then years and years after, this doll museum had been constructed over the place."
Mark: Why?
Woman: "What the heck is it?"
Mark: What the heck indeed!
Indeed!
Wilhelm: "I think you will wonder what's happening with the guy who was being the host."
"No doubt with a Satan curse."
Mark: The Satin curse.
Wilhelm: "He was successful in the life that he wanted for a short period of time."
"His life was like a dream for fifteen years."
"Unfortunately, he found out that it was not as good as it should have been."
"Later, he had found out that the ritual was not complete."
"Someone was gone from the ritual."
"That irritated him so much."
"But finally, he know who was the final one."
Mark: Is it me?
Is it me?
Wilhelm: "Yes."
Mark: Me?
Wilhelm: [Mark: Yay!] "The final one- [Mark: Haha.] -is you, Miss Walterson!"
Mark: That doesn't make any sense.
*strange noise*
Hey, ow, my face.
Why you do that?
I knew he wasn't dead!
Oh, save game?
Sav- Save game?
Okay.
Wilhelm: "Ahh! The big mistake from fifteen years ago will end. [Mark: We could not.] My demonic rituals and everything will be complete!"
Mark: How about we don't?
Wilhelm: "All suffering will be gone!"
Mark: No, thank you.
Wilhelm: Hahaha!
*Walterson groans in pain*
Wilhelm: "Oh, I'm sorry, Miss Walterson. Did I wake you up?"
Mark: Huh.
Wilhelm: "Don't you know that I have been looking for you for a long, long time?"
Mark: No, I didn't know.
Wilhelm: "But at last, I found YOU."
Mark: Okay.
Wilhelm: "I didn't expect that you would become a detective."
"It looks like you want to know about your past."
"Yes, I will grant you your wish."
Mark: Okay.
Wilhelm: "I would like to introduce someone to you, too."
Mark: Oh, boy!
Wilhelm: That someone is Satan, who whispered to me."
Mark: Okay.
Wilhelm: "I really like its soul."
Mark: Oh.
Wilhelm: "Yes. Satan said that your mom was so delicious."
Mark: Ah, that's a weird thing to say.
*Wilhelm laughs*
Mark: In multiple ways.
Wilhelm: "Now, it's time to see your mother."
Mark: Oh. Lovely!
Family reunions are always good. *Wilhelm laughs*
HAHAHAHA- oh, hi.
Oh, oh, oh my God, okay. Well, this was unexpe- oh my God.
Are you kidding me?
This is awesome! *giggle*
This is awesom-
AH Hey, hey, stop that.
Hey- Stop it.
Stop it
You're f-super freaky
And I- Ooh heart
Oh- ayeee
There we go.
I found your weakness.
It's your- your-
Conspicuously open heart.
And stabbing mechanisms won't work because I'm all the way back here. :(
*pew pew pew*
Who knew that I could have guns in Hell?!
oh boi
incoming.
ooh boi- ow my face
ow my face
*pew pew pew pew pewdiepie pew pew*
woooooooah
YEAH!! I KILLED SATAN!!
I killed him! I killed him dead!
He's dead now! (jeez mark)
I am the winner! (yeah okay)
of Hell? I guess I get that now?
That's nice I-I suppose
Oh shit.
Ah fuck.
You thought they would've learned their lesson the first time.
..when they built the museum of horrifying dolls on top of the
flaming wreckage of a
an abandoned orphanage
filled with DEAD CHILDREN because
someone probably would've known about it.
Also, how did she survive??
How did she escape??
She tuck and rolled as a toddler out the window
but somehow didn't learn those skills now?
As a toddler:
*touches forehead* "OH GOD DEMONIC FIRE!"
you BUST outta the window
roll a few feet
hit your head, lose your memory,
then become a detective and lose all those survival skills.
except when you get a gun and shoot Satan in the heart.
But either way, that was The Final One.
The name makes sense now, I totally get it.
There were some
hiccups in this
but it's outweighed by the fact that I
actually really enjoyed the gameplay.
Obviously, the narration wasn't perfect because
they didn't speak English as their first language,
um
but this was good.
It had good flow to it,
and I actually liked the combat.
I haven't said that about a horror game, in a long time,
and I think it's because it's reminiscent of Cry of Fear.
There were a diverse number of enemies,
for how short the game was,
There were like three different enemy types.
Four if you include the first doll that came after you,
but
i-it's just really interesting to see how
combat /can/ work,
if you have a diverse enough
environment and enemy type
that keeps things interesting.
But either way, I'll leave it at that.
Lemme know what you guys thought of it down in the comments below.
I am going to rest my tounge.
I don't know how I'm gonna do that,
and that just sounds weird when I say it out loud,
But I'm gonna...do just that but
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
And as always,
I will see you-
in the next video.
Buh bye!
*Outro Music*
Thanks for watching! :D